[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france donc on le voit
la tension monte sérieusement entre
pékin et washington donald trump menace
même maintenant de ne plus parler à la
chine est ce que c'est un simple bluff
selon vous où on est vraiment en
présence d'un vrai risque de rupture
diplomatique
lorsqu'on parle du présent 30 on ne peut
jamais savoir la plupart du temps ils
aiment effectivement bluffé il aime dire
qu'il va faire des choses et ensuite
changé ta fille mais nous avons
également vu par le passé qu'il a dit
des choses à propos de la chine par
exemple en matière de commerce et il a
respecté ses engagements
donc on ne sait pas ce qu'il va arriver
à ce que les états unis seront aussi
stricte avec hashim que le présent jeudi
ont-ils essayé d'imposer des tarifs
punitifs à la chine c'est très possible
il faut garder à l'esprit que pour le
moment le président essaye de gérer la
crise dans son pays et les médias sont
extrêmement cruel avec lui concernant
ces actions est ce que l'on considère
comme ses échecs
le président doit donc pouvoir accuser
quelqu'un d'autre et la chine semblent
une cible privilégiée
alors on rappelle à l'origine de ces
tensions washington qui accuse pékin
d'ailleurs depuis le début d'avoir caché
la gravité de ce virus là ça va plus
loin on parle d'avoir caché cet accident
dans le laboratoire de mourad qui serait
à l'origine de la pandémie
pourquoi s'acharner sur ces accusations
maintenant quel est l'intérêt de donald
trump
voilà au mieux de gérer la crise est
peut-être régler ses comptes après
pourquoi maintenant c'est une très bonne
question et je pense qu'une partie du
problème c'est que la gestion de la
crise semble dépassée qui que ce soit à
washington la jeune femme ne fait que
réagir ne gère rien du tout il ne
contrôle rien du tout donc si l'on
observe ce qui se passe à washington en
ce moment en matière tête économique
c'est effectivement
ces réactions et pas des actions
décisives ils sont à la traîne par
rapport à la crise nous ne testons pas
encore de manière systématique aux états
unis cet incroyable lorsque on voit
l'argent dont bénéficier des états unis
l'argent que nous sommes en train
d'imprimer et pourtant ne pouvons pas
encore mené des tests nous n'avons pas
non plus utile d'écouter les anticorps
et combien de personnes ont des
anticorps d'un système en ce moment même
donc le fait que les politiques ne sont
pas conditionnées par les sciences où
les données sont dus au fait qu'il n'a
pas assez pour le moment cela fait deux
mois que la crise a commencé nous sommes
encore bien trop en retard donc je pense
que l'administration est vraiment
désemparés ne sait pas comment faire
pour prendre de l'avancé par rapport à
la crise et le pensent qu'aux élections
à venir
comment transformer présenter la chose
afin que lors des élections nous
pourrions nous puissions défendre nos
actions les américains aiment l'idée
d'avoir un ennemi commun quelqu'un qui
est en fait le monstre qu'il faut
arrêter et donald trump se joue là
dessus c'est la chine le monstre c'est
eux qui ont créé un virus donc toutes
les conséquences sont imputables de la
chine alors on en a parlé tout à l'heure
il ya aussi maintenant les accusations
d'espionnage selon laquelle les hackers
chinois auraient tenté de s'emparer de
recherche américaine sur le vaccin alors
là ce n'est pas de donald trump par mais
le fbi et le département de la sécurité
intérieure qui sont à l'origine de ces
accusations est ce qu'elles semblent
juger crédible notamment aux états unis
cela ne semble pas forcément crédible
mais nous avons tant entendu pour parler
de hackers et de piratage vous avez
entendu parler de hackers russes lors
des élections de 2016
et au cours de semaine dernière on a
encore parlé et cela s'est avéré fraude
grâce à des documents qui viennent
d'être publiés la semaine passée donc il
y à une crise de confiance
s'agissant de beaucoup d'accusations les
autorités légales de ce pays ils le plui
pas leurs informations il ne donne pas
de preuves ils disent des choses et
disent que c'est la vérité et le public
commence à se méfier mais il ya un
problème plus important c'est que blâmer
la chine peut présenter des avantages
politiques au lait je ne pense pas que
sur le long terme cela aura du succès
car nous avons des millions de de
d'américains au chômage des millions
d'américains qui demandent des
prestations chômage
héliades emilie également deux
entrepreneurs qui n'ont pas encore reçu
dette
donc il s'en fiche qui est responsable
ils veulent des réponses quant à la
façon dont on va les aider eux et
malheureusement washington ne réussit
pas à apporter ses réponses au niveau du
président mais également au niveau du
congrès en ligne de mire évidemment la
présidentielle de novembre
merci à vous benson d'avoir été avec nos
journalistes d'investigation pour notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir